So, I hope you remember from the last lecture the concepts of convolution and
cross-correlation.
We'd looked at in detail, this was how we denote the symbol for
doing convolution between a kernel and an input image to get an output.
Just related also the convolution method.
The big difference between them is how we loop around the matrix or
the input image to be able to then assign attributes from the filter.
And basically, using this method,
we can apply various types of filters to process images.
And we actually looked at how we can do this for
doing noise removal and blurring and smoothing of images.
Of course, you should by now remember that depending on h, if it's symmetric or
not, you have to choose which one of these to apply.